>> Greg: SQUAD MEMBER
ILHAN OMAR DOESN'T REGRET TO
PARRY ISRAEL TO TERRORIST
GROUPS, LAUNCHED A NEW ATTACK ON
JEWISH MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> DO YOU REGRET THESE COMMENTS?
>> I DON'T, I WELCOME ANY TIME
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION, TO LEARN FROM
THEM, TO LEARN FROM ME, I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THESE
MEMBERS TO REALIZE THAT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN PARTNERS IN
INJUSTICE, THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
EQUALLY ENGAGING IN SEEKING
JUSTICE AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Greg: OMAR ISN'T GETTING
ANY SUPPORT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> ANY ATTEMPT TO DRAW AN
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND A CLOSE ALLY
ISRAEL AND A TERRORIST GROUP
LIKE HAMAS AND THE TALIBAN IS
FALSE AND REPREHENSIBLE.
IT WAS NOT THE INTENT OF HER
COMMENT BUT THOSE CERTAINLY WERE
NOT COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE FROM
HERE.
>> Greg: DOES SHE HELP THE
WHITE HOUSE?
IN A WAY BY BEING SO RADICAL THE
WHITE HOUSE LOOKS MORE MODERATE
IN COMPARISON.
>> Harold: CLEARLY SHE DOESN'T
HELP THE WHITE HOUSE, DOESN'T
HELP DEMOCRATS AND I WOULD ARGUE
IF YOU TRY TO LOOK AT HER WORDS
IN THE MOST FAVORABLE LIGHT,
THAT SHE IS INDEED LOOKING TO
BRING ABOUT A SOLUTION TO
CHALLENGES IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
SHE DOESN'T HELP THAT CAUSE
EITHER.
I THINK IN FACT SHE PUSHES BACK
THE OPPORTUNITY OR CHANCE TO
FIND ANY KIND OF COMMON GROUND,
I DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHAT
SHE'S SAYING.
IT SOUNDED THAT HER WORDS ON
PAPER SOUNDED LIKE SHE WAS
DRAWING AN EQUIVALENCE BETWEEN
US, THE UNITED STATES AND TERROR
ORGANIZATIONS, ARE MOST RELIABLE
ALLY IN THE REGION.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE'S SAYING
THAT'S NOT THE CASE, SHE'S
MAKING YOURSELF A CANDIDATE FOR
SOME SORT OF ACTION IN CONGRESS
IF THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
SHE BELIEVES, MAYBE REMOVAL FROM
THE COMMITTEE HAS TO BE THOUGHT
ABOUT IF SHE SHARES THESE VIEWS.
I SAW WHAT I BELIEVE WAS A
RECANTING ON HER PART AND NOW I
AM SADLY CONFUSED.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY NEED A
PEACEMAKER CAUCUS WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE HERE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER IF WE CAN GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
>> Greg: IT'S PRETTY
INTERESTING, DANA, I DON'T KNOW
HER TOTAL HISTORY BUT SHE DID
FLEE A COUNTRY, SOMALIA, SHE
COMES TO THE FREEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH BUT HER CRITICISM IS
ALWAYS KIND OF BORN OF AMERICA
BEING OPPRESSIVE SO SHE FLED TO
A TRULY OPPRESSIVE EXPERIENCE,
COMES HERE AND SEES US AS
SOMEHOW MORE OPPRESSIVE THAN
ANYTHING OUT THERE.
>> Dana: THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I THINK WHAT HAROLD
IS SAYING IS TRUE, SHE IS
COMPLETELY UNPERSUASIVE, IF SHE
HAD POINTS SHE COULD MAKE THAT
WERE PERSUASIVE ABOUT WHAT SHE'S
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND WOULD BE A HOME RUN
FOR PALESTINIANS, THAT'S NOT
WHAT SHE SAID.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE,
GLENN BARRY AT THE PODIUM WHEN
SHE GOT THE
METAL, GOT THIRD.
THAT'S REALLY UNPERSUASIVE,
SHE'S NOT ABLE TO STAND UP AND
SAY "I LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND
BECAUSE I LOVE THIS COUNTRY I
WOULD LOVE FOR US TO STAND UP
FOR JUSTICE.
I THINK THESE PEOPLE DESERVE
BETTER JUSTICE AND I WANT TO
WORK FOR THAT."
IF SHE WAS SAYING THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WOULD HAVE TO SAY,
REPEATEDLY, "WE DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT" AND I DON'T THINK SHE
DESERVES THE PATH ANY LONGER
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
B3 IT MUST BE CHALLENGING FOR
THE MEDIA BENDING OVER BACKWARDS
NOT TO CRITICIZE HER BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO JUST SHUT UP,
MAYBE YOU CAN BECOME PRESIDENT,
YOUR BROTHER CAN BE FIRST DUTY.
>> Katie: THE MEDIA IS ACCUSED
OF ISLAMOPHOBIA EVERY TIME THEY
CRITICIZE HER SO SHE USES THAT
AS A SHIELD FOR HER OWN BIGOTRY,
SHE IS DEALING WITH REAL POLICY
ISSUES THAT AFFECT ALLIES LIKE
ISRAEL WHILE MAKING THIS INSANE
MORAL EQUIVALENCE BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES, ISRAEL AND U.S.
GOVERNMENT STATE DEPARTMENT
SANCTIONS AND PUT ON THE SUB
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS AROUND
THE WORLD, THAT WE HAVE FOUGHT
WARS OVER END AMERICANS HAVE
DIED FIGHTING AGAINST, PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ATTACKED US ON OUR OWN
SOIL SO IT IS FAR BEYOND TIME,
NOT JUST JEWISH DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE CONDEMN HER ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI BECAUSE THE LAST
TIME THIS HAPPENED TWO OR THREE
WEEKS AGO THERE WAS SOME
CONDEMNATION, NANCY PELOSI SAID
I AM NOT CONDEMNING HER SO
PLEASE DON'T MISCONSTRUE THAT
BUT TODAY YOU HAD ILHAN OMAR
TRYING TO WALK THIS BACK ON HER
TWITTER FEED WITH THIS
GOBBLEDYGOOK OF
INTERSECTIONALITY IN INJUSTICE
AND IN HER ORIGINAL REMARK SHE
SAID JEWISH COLLEAGUES OF HERS
IN THE HOUSE HAVE NOT BEEN GOOD
PARTNERS IN INJUSTICE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO HER?
DOES NOT MEAN TAKING AWAY
FUNDING FOR THE IRON DOME THAT
PROTECTS MILLIONS OF ISRAELI
LIES AND PALESTINIAN LIVES AND
LIVES IN ISRAEL, IS THAT WHAT
SHE MEANS BY THAT?
WE HAVE ENOUGH HISTORY BASED ON
HER STATEMENTS IF THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT SHE MEANS.
>> Greg: JESSE, EVERY SITE HAS
AN EXTREME, AN EXTREME PERSON,
YOU ARE ONE OF OURS.
THE MEDIA EXCUSES THE LEFT,
SOMEHOW THE LEFT GETS TO GO MUCH
FURTHER UNTIL IT'S NO LONGER
TENABLE.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE KOOKS ON
BOTH SIDE.
THEY ARE KOOKS ARE HATING THE
COUNTRY.
SHE'S BEEN SMACKED DOWN BY THE
WHITE HOUSE, SHE'S HAVING A
TOUGH YEAR.
I'M GOING TO LOOK AT HER IN AN
UNFAVORABLE LIGHT AND TAKE THE
COMMENTS SHE MADE LITERALLY.
THE TALIBAN CONDONED ATROCITIES,
ATTACKS AGAINST CHILDREN,
ATTACKS AGAINST CIVILIANS, THE
UNITED STATES DO NOT CONDONE ANY
OF THAT SO SHE SAYS SHE'S ALL
ABOUT, SHE SUFFERED INJUSTICE.
SHE PROBABLY SUFFERED A LITTLE
BUT AS A REFUGEE THIS COUNTRY
RESCUED HER, BROUGHT HER HERE
AND ELECTED HER INTO CONGRESS,
WE PAY HER HEALTH CARE AND
SALARY AND SHE'S VIOLATING ALL
SORTS OF ETHICS LAWS AND
IMMIGRATION LAWS ACCORDING TO
REPORTS SO CNN IS TRYING TO
REHAB HER, THEY EXPECTED HER TO
SAY YES, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
AND SHE JUST FLAT OUT REJECTE